abone ol
Herkese
merhabalar ben Nazife Bilgin Hazar Ben
49 yaşına kadar ya Sabah kahveleri olan
günleri olan E boş vakitlerinde de
yağlıboya akrilik karakalem çalışmaları
yapan bir ev hanımı iken evinin iki oğlu
ve bu çalışmalarına Tanık olan iki oğlu
benim Mersin Üniversitesi Güzel Sanatlar
Fakültesi resim bölünmeye girmem için
teşvik ettiler ve bende 49 yaşında yani
2011 yılında Mersin Üniversitesi Güzel
Sanatlar Fakültesi resim bölümüne girdim
v2015 yılında da ya 100lük Siz de bunu
hani övünerek değil İnsan isterse her
yaşta herşeyi başarabilir 100'lük
sistemde 98.50 dokuzla mezun olarak
bitirdim şu anda yüksek lisans
öğrencisiyim tezimi yazdığım Hatta bir
ay sonra da şey yapacağım teslim
edeceğim ben ilk doğa resmi çalışmamı
Mersin Üniversitesi'nde okurken 2.
sınıfta atölye hocamızın vize ve final
ödevi olarak ve okulumuza Yeni kurulan
hayvan geçici Bakımevi nin dış cephesini
renklendirme mizi istediği her öğrenciye
birer duvar verdi bu duvarda benim
bayağı büyükçe bir
duvar the eve ben orada gördüğünüz gibi
böyle bir çalışma yaptım ama bu çalışma
biraz çok meşakkatli oldu çünkü bize
sprey boyalar vermişlerdir Men sprey
boyaların uçlar olurmuş kalından inceye
doğru bana verilen bizlere verilen de
çok kalın uçlu Hadi gördüğünüz gibi
figüratif bir çalışma olduğu için ben
artık o sprey boyayı kapağını sıkarak
tanrıçalarla beraber ve bu çalışmayı ben
tamamladım biraz meşakatli olarakta ama
ben duvar resmini çok sevdim Ve bunun
akabinde okurken çocuk ceza evinden bir
teklif geldi oranın duvarların
renklendirdi mhta Bunlar gardiyan Beyler
Onlar daha çok güzel Beraber çalış bir
sosyal sorumluluk projesi altında ben
çok yere imza attım birincisi bu tıp
fakültesindeki anestezi bölümü
yemekhanesinin duvarını resmetti sosyal
sorumluluk projesi altında bir Amatem
biraz rhymer Derneği bir otizm Kreşi Han
unuttuklarım da olabilir Çok yere duvar
resimleri yaptım asıl zaten çok önemli
proje 2017 yılında Mersin Toroslar
Belediyesi Başkanı'nın geçmiş dönem
Belediye Başkanı bana getirmiş olduğu
bir proje edip belki mersini bilen
vardır Çünkü bizim birak Beren Güneykent
bir daha Kent Konutları mız var
38-39 yıllık olan bu konutların dış
cephesine
renklendirme mi yani sanatçılarla
alakalı resimler yapmamı istedi bu zaten
toplu konutlar
orta halli insanların oturduğu Yani
şöyle civar Sen neden köylerden ekonomik
sebeplerden dolayı gelen Güneykent
Güneydoğu'dan gelenlerin oturduğu ikamet
ettiği toplu konutlar ve öp Öyle olunca
tabi toplu konutların dış cepheleri Hani
zamanla iç bir tadilatın yapılmaması
tabi zamanla yıpranmasına artı bir de
çevre kirliliğine neden olmuştu bende
Şöyle düşündük Başkanla beraber Ben
dedim ki sanatsal ve kültürel
faaliyetleri çok uzak olan halkı sanatla
buluşturmak yani müzedeki sanatı halkın
ayağına getirmek ilk önce zaten İşte
gördüğünüz gibi bir çalışmalarla bu 2017
yılında bununla başladım ve daha sonra
işte bu zaten burada gördükleriniz
duvarın öncesi Daha sonra da sonrası
adlı çalışmaları İşte en kötü duvar
zaten Van Gogh'un yıldızlı gece
çalışmasıydı bir de yaptığım çalışmaları
zaten ha ya hani bu duvara ne
yakışabilir beni düşündüren en çok
duvarda zaten bu olmuştu Hani gördüğünüz
gibi çok eski binalar olduğu için hani
Dışarıdan çok afedersin tuvalet boruları
geçiyorsun oraları geçiyor
klimanın motorları geçiyor onları da
Kamufle ederek ten ona göre çalışmalar
seçiyorum ve Bu çalışmalar işte bakın
Gördüğünüz gibi bütün duvarlar
güneykentte akbelende ve halk kentteki
duvarların eski önceki hali ve sonraki
hali ve ben burada
Buradaki amaç zaten binaların çehresini
güzelleştirmek farklı bir ruh katmak
orada oturan kişilerin duygu ve
düşüncelerinin bir adım daha ileriye
gitmesini sağlamaktır ve gerçekten de
amacına ulaştığını da hani düşünüyorum
çünkü burada oturanlar hep şunu
söylüyorlar Çünkü beş beş yıldız zaten
ben bu şey dedim bu toplu konutlarda
çalışmalar yapıyorum
2017'den itibaren Şimdi de zaten
güneykentte bu dönem Belediye Başkanı
benden
akbelendeki projenin devamını istedi ben
de severek dedim Çünkü doğa resimleri
zaten en büyük katkısı sanatın belli bir
kesimin zaten gidebileceği artı
gidebilir herkesin Çünkü oradaki yaşayan
insanlarla Hani zaten sohbet ettiğin
zaman hani bir galeriye bir müzeye
gidemedik lerinden bahsetmişlerdir işi
işte belli bir kesimin zaten hani
gidebileceği Siz parasal değeri satılık
bir nesne konumundan
çıkartılarak Tan o durumu sanatın daha
sosyal bir platforma taşımakta yani
kentsel li alanları kamusal alanları
renkli Duvarlarla resimlerle canlandırma
bir sel boşlukları güzelleştirmektir ve
amacına da ulaştığını düşünüyorum ben
biraz çabuk geçeceğim Çünkü bu slaytlar
çok çok uzun Bunlar da benim yaptığım
çalışmaların yan taraflarına ne
yapabilirim onlar tamamen bana ait
panjurlar var perdeler var perdelerde
Eskiden yerlere çıkardık Biz dantel
perdeler işler dik ve onları Ben
Buralara resmettim Bunların hepsi şeyde
Evet bir uğra ya Artı böyle bir şeyim
oldu çalışmam oldu
Daha sonra işte Evet az rhymer derneği
bu acayip derneğinde biliyorsunuz
geçmişe yönelik yaşayan
insanların olduğu hastaların olduğu bir
dernek Hatta Bununla ilgili bir anım
oldu benim ben akbelende iken biraz
rhymer hastası evinden çıkıyor ve yolunu
bulamıyor oradaki Mahal oy koluna
girmişler Hani evin nerede tarif etmeye
çalışıyor ama çok hatırlayamadığı için
bayağı diyor muhallebi Gezmişler ama en
son on Osman Hamdi Bey'in geçti zaten
Osman Hamdi Bey'in Ben halı satıcısı
çalışmasını yapmıştık Çünkü orada
satıcılar Osmanlı dönemine ait e
satıcılar halılar ve kilimler var ve o
beyfendi hasta olan beyefendi gelmiş
bakmış demiş ki benim evim bunun
arkasında ve ben o kadar duygulandım ya
bazı resimlerin de insanlara ne kadar
faydalı olabileceğini her yönden ya
Sadece o değil adres belirleme de bu
işte bir Amatem çalışması araya Çünkü
böyle sosyal sorumluluk projesi altında
çalışmalarda ilave ediyorum Evet bu da
Güneykent projen Bu da böyle devam Bu
İşte gördüğünüz gibi binalar çok çok
kötü E ben genelde uluslararası çok üne
sahip eserlerin Hatta orijinalinin kat
be kat üstünde Çünkü gördüğünüz gibi
3'er ve çoğunlukla ama dört katlı
binaların dış cephesine ben resmediyorum
bir de haftamız figüratif çalışmaları
çok seviyor Çünkü ben bunu akbelende şey
yapmıştım bir anket yapmıştım bu çok çok
sıcak mersinimiz Evet genelde işte Bu
istinat duvarı hiç boş durmayı da çok
sevmiyorum genelde hava çok sıcak olduğu
zaman istinat duvarında bir de buradaki
yapılan çalışmaların
gerek gençlerin gerek yata yaşlıların
Ama özellikle tabi gençlerin çocukların
ilgisi yadsınamaz Yani bunu görmeniz ve
yaşamanız lazım Ben 5 yıldır çünkü hani
gerek akbelende gerek Güneykent hala
Güneykent derim Çünkü bu da çok Bu proje
anne bunu da bitmesi benim tahminim
eylül ekim Belki de Kasım'da olabilir
İşte gördüğünüz gibi Hatta burada Bunu
ben yaparken oradan İki geçen beş şunu
söylediği hiç unutmuyorum gibi bizde de
eskiden burada Yürüyüş yaparken İnanır
mısınız biz buraya dönüp bakmaz dık
Yürüyüş yaparken hemen geçerdik ve ben
şey olaraktan Hatta şimdi duruyoruz dedi
Halil paşa kim veya yaptığım çalışmayı
daha sonra eve gidip Biz bunu Sayar'dan
yaptığı çalışmaları hayatını dedik
rahatlıkla şey yapabiliyoruz
öğrenebiliyoruz dedi bütün bu kadar
güzel şeyler aslında bir sanat çok
uzağız gibi ama ben bu yaptığım dua
resimlerinden hem geçeyim Hem size
anlatayım şunu gördüm ki aslında bir
sanat hocasıyım koruyoruz dolu hatta
Mahalleli diyor ki Eskiden buraya kimse
dönüp bakmaz kendi your Evet şimdi diyor
şehir başka ucundan Evet çünkü bizim bu
konutlar Mersin'in kuzeyinde ve ve çok
atılmaz diye Duran konuklar the işim
diyor dışarıdan geliyor bu şehir içinden
şehir dışından başından geliyorlar
fotoğraf çektiriyorlar arabalar duruyor
Bu onların o kadar çok hoşuna gidiyor ki
kendimizi diyor çok önemli hissediyoruz
Yani bizden artık
mersin.bel kişi ne çıt yaklaştık Çünkü
merkezden geliyorlar bize gidiyorlar ve
onların o mutluluğu görmek gözlerindeki
ışıltıyı görmek
anlatamam bir Şehit evine İstek üzerine
yapılan bayrak çalışması hani böyle
çalışmalarımda olur
evet evet evet çok ses getiren bir proje
oldu yani akbelende başladı zaten Çünkü
çok ünlü Canon ye basın kuruluşu bu
teknoloji ve
dışında günün fotoğrafı seçildi Evet
yani burada artık ben şöyle diyorum hani
Mersin imizin belki biliyorsunuzdur bu
Aslında her şehir için geçerli
yemyeşil bahçeleri vardı eve
bahçelerimiz vardı antika evlerimiz
vardı tarihi evlerimiz vardı şimdi o
binalar O Yerler hep inanırım şimdi
imara verilmiş ve hepsi artık bir
betonerme yılında dönüşmeye başladım ben
de diyorum ki bu mersinimiz için belki
biz çok da olsa Bu proje yani hoş bana
göre büyük ama bu proje belki mersinimiz
için büyük bir teselli armağanıdır diye
düşünüyorum ve bu duvar resimlerine
insanların ilgisi o kadar güzel
kişi anlatamam ve öğrenciler geliyor
izliyorlar al Ha bir de şöyle bir
durumda oldu artık kişilerin
sanat nesnesini tüketen alkışlayan Pasif
bir izleyici
durumundayken Artık gelip fotoğraf
diyorlar Bol bol fotoğraf çekiyorlar
sesli videolar çekiyorlar çünkü hani
beraber sohbet ediyoruz Ben kovalar
araçta çalışırken yanıma kadar
geliyorlar ve bunu sosyal medyada
paylaşıyorlar artık estetik algılarımı
da değiştiğini
Ben Hemen gözüme hale görüyoruz ve
içtiklerini de fark ediyorum gerçekten
Bence
sanat dünyayı kurtaracak sanat artık
sokaklarda Rio kadar mutlu oluyorlar
Yani bir müze ymiş bir Galeri imiş bu
şeyleri ayaklarına getirmek artık
gündelik yaşamlarının da bir parçası
oldu ha bu sorular böyle mutlulukla hani
çok
uğursuz baktığımız zaman bile bir
Pencereye açıyoruz bir neye bakarak tan
kahve içiyoruz veya bir İbrahim
Çallı'nın yapmış olduğu yeşil elbiseli
kadın çalışmasında ama Ooo prenses
şifrem oranın çalışması yapmış İbrahim
Bey Öyle olunca Hani ben sabah kalkınca
diyorum ki cep Günaydın için veya bir
yaşlı halayık yaptım o kadar güzel yani
Her resimde İnanır mısınız o kadar güzel
anılarım var ki bir de Oradaki
insanların Hani sanatı veya resim
sanatını diyeyim artık şöyle
düşünüyorlarmış ay fırçayı Eline alınca
kadın hemen yapacak bana ilk sordukları
soru buldum akbelende iken Bu resim
yarın bitecek mi Ne dedim ki yarın olsun
Elif Kararınızı verin veya bir bu daha
sonra işte geliyorlar ay daha bitmediği
halde görüyorlar zaten beni naklini
diyorlar öğrenciler yeri geldiğinde
okuldan geliyorlar oraya oturuyorlar
izliyorlar ve artık bir çalışmanın bir
günde bir döneceğini bu sanatın yaptığım
çalışır resim sanatının çok meşakkatli
olduğunu hale görüyorlar ve beni
gerçekten tebrik ediyorlar ve ben
diyorum ki artık Sanat Sokak ve Dünya'yı
Bence Sanat en son Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk'ün çok önemli bir sözü var
şanssız kalan bir toplumun Hayat zaman
verip müşterek Çok teşekkür ederim sanat
ve Sevgiyle kalın Çok sağ olun
abone ol